welcome to Hari Saba's a channel where
we discussed the latest tech news and
dove into newest tech product so as you
guys already know the i7 8700 K is
really great but the 9700 K or the 8800
K is going to be absolutely spectacular
but should you wait for it but before we
delve into that make sure to hit that
subscribe button if you guys would like
to stay updated with the latest tech
news related to gaming at pcs so just
ask some context Andy has been forcing
Intel to bring out more cores and better
value ever since the release of Rison
this definitely worked and forced Intel
to add two cores to their coffee like
CPU and rush its release as well however
even despite that Ryan is still by far
the bio King and Intel is yet to
introduce octa-core to the mainstream
platform while AMD has had two
generations now with octa-core honors
mainstream platform as a result an
octa-core mainstream processor from
Intel should not be far from release and
if we look at in toast roadmap for this
year they have something called Z 390
which is coming out in the second half
of 2018 and that may be what this is all
about this new platform definitely does
not seem to be ice lake or cannon league
but Intel would have simply named that Z
470 instead of Z 390 so this new
platform definitely seems to be an
upgraded version of coffee League with
more cores and the new chipset was
probably created to be able to fulfill
the increased power supply needs an
octa-core processor would need compared
to the other conflicts abuse so pretty
much all this context coincides and
suggest that the Z 390 platform that is
coming out later this year will probably
support the 9700 K or the 8800 K which
will be an octa-core coffee-like
processor so how exactly will it perform
and what will expect speed well let's
get the obvious out of the way first
it's obviously going to have eight cores
and 16 threads but unfortunately it's
still gonna stay on the 14 animator
process and not move on to 10 nanometer
I don't think we'll see it an animator
crosses onto a cannon lake or ice lake
or whatever comes out next for the z400
series as for clock speed I think we can
safely assume that the 8800 K or
whatever the CPU will be called will
beat the 78 20 X because if you look at
the 8700 K which is pretty much
identical to the 7800 X the a similar K
was rushed but Intel was still able to
beat this 70 Hunter's excess base clock
by point two gears so for this cpu intel
has had a long time to work on it and
perfected so I definitely think that
they will be able to beat the base clock
speed of the octa-core 78 20x also when
the 87 arcade came out
Intel had to be really cautious not to
cannibalize their own series but at this
point they already know that the
enthusiasts line isn't doing too well
and they already couldn't discontinue
keep you like X and lower-level sky like
X processors aren't doing too much
better either also it has been more time
since those chips came out so it would
be more acceptable for Intel to beat
them in performance so I think that the
most probable base clock speed up for
this new octa-core processor will be 3.7
or 3.8 gigahertz and the boost clock
speed will be anywhere from four point
two to four point five years and for all
you extreme overclockers out there I
definitely think that this should be
able to reach 5 gigahertz but anything
you know at least reach 4.8 gigahertz
just like all of those other high-end
CPUs so that's pretty much all we have
for performance of this chip this chip
should also have better power
consumption than these Sambia 20x which
needed 140 watts so pretty much this new
chip will be a rebranded and upgraded
version of the 78 20 X okay but second
half of 2018 is quite a big time frame
so when exactly will it come out during
that period well last year the 8700 K
was released in October and I believe
that that is the most probable month
that this new CPU will come out as well
if it doesn't come out any earlier than
that I highly doubt that Intel will come
out with this new chip in November or
December but is that's holiday season of
this year and that will drive many sales
for Intel so I really doubt that Intel
will
miss out on their opportunity so most
likely I think we can expect to see this
chip in August to October of this year
that way by the time that holiday season
and Black Friday rolls around there will
be a lot of established reviews and
benchmarks online which will persuade
more people to buy their chips so I
think that's the most probable release
timeframe for this new chip so what
about price this is definitely the most
important factor when determining if you
are going to wait or not so how does the
price look for this chip
well the 78 20x came out for an MSRP of
599 dollars but when that came out vicen
still wasn't that established and Intel
was still dominated market so they can
get away with such outrageous prices but
now times are different just a couple
weeks ago amy released 2700 X which is
an octa-core processor with a really
good CPU cooler for just three hundred
and twenty-nine dollars so as a result
there's no way to Intel is going to be
able to get away with such ridiculous
pricing I think the absolute maximum
reasonable price that in talk can charge
is $500 I really doubt that they will
break that limit because that just won't
drive sales
if Intel really wants to be competitive
I bet that they could offer this chip
for just three hundred and eighty
dollars and that would be great but
unfortunately
intohe still has that monopoly and they
do offer better clock speed and Rison so
I think that the most probable range for
this chip will be four hundred to five
hundred dollars as for a z3 90
motherboards most motherboards will
costs from $180 to 220 others and there
may be some budget oriented ones for
about one hundred and fifty dollars
right and that's the lowest will go so
if you want this chip then be prepared
to spend 600 to 700 dollars on the chip
and motherboard so finally should you
wait well first of all you obviously
have to be able to afford it but what I
think is more important than the price
itself is if the product is worth that
price this CPU is gonna be great in all
but at the same time I don't think
that's offering great value it's just a
premium product for a premium price for
all you guys looking to buy Rison
I definitely think that you guys should
just go ahead and buy that this new CPU
is not gonna even come close to the
value without offers and if this new CPU
is simply not worth the extra money that
is asking really the only people who
should wait for this chip are people who
are considering to buy the 8700 K right
now but are also willing to spend a bit
more money if you're in that category
you guys should definitely wait for this
news chip business only be like $100
more but it'll provide you with much
more spectacular performance and
obviously you guys are into that when
you're spending three hundred and eighty
dollars on 8700 K right now this may
also be a great option for small scale
business owners who use their computers
to make money this will offer really
great performance without costing too
much money so overall this new CPU is
gonna be insane and really offer a great
performance but at the same time it
really is a premium product and unless
you want to spend premium prices there's
no reason to wait for it so what do you
guys think are you guys excited that
Intel is bringing octa-core to the
mainstream platform and that AMD is
putting so much pressure on Intel or
could you care less because you're just
gonna go by AMD anyways make sure to
post down in comments below what you
guys think because I do read all my
comments and I'm curious as to what you
guys think so make sure to post your
thoughts also if you guys like this
video then make sure to hit that like
button and consider subscribing if you
guys would like to see more videos just
like this every single day but until
next time bye
you
[Music]